hello and welcome into this video hmm
sorry for my voice yeah after a training
session sometimes he's a little bit
under the weather okay so i got this
before in here this English opening
looks like white has accomplished his
some main goal here what now might have
three or d 3 and I thought d3 I guess
keep the night flexible
I would nervous about that unprotected
piece on c3 but I don't really see what
he might be able to do to get some
benefit out of it I don't see it going
to do seven yeah this is normally played
to get um b6 going but I have be 50 k
nite h3 is possible only might have a
five that ok so let's do this probably
will go look B aid okay all that was
fairly fairly logical age 3 is just a
wedding move to be honest I want to see
what he's doing
and those positions are are more
complicated than they look first you're
thinking there is no real contact behind
between the two sites so not much is
going on but in fact there is quite
substantial struggle because the paw
information in the center is some very
flexible and there are many different
ways of setting this up for example now
this is 64 as a transformation of the
central pawn structure that it's not
easy to evaluate what I didn't I didn't
want to allow a very easy d5 one thing
that have to be aware of quite often it
is desirable to play Bishop e3 and
deform in this so-called Botvinnik
structure with CY differ but here d4c
takes Knight X leaves a c4 porn very
weak so this is something that I have to
consider with some coercion so here
again I'm on d5 so it's not what is
going to play just right now and that
that was something I expected ok so
community too and he will very likely go
nitey form you will not go night if
that's that move I did not expect at all
ok I think I'm going to trade his bishop
as this should be helpful
okay so here yeah well Bishop g5 doesn't
really doesn't really do much okay so
I'm taking this first job I think I want
to take him making opening the diagonal
and now now maybe defy that makes some
sense actually opening this up now as I
mentioned okay c4 week ish but that's
not relevant here anymore after year has
weakened his some his King so enormously
it will be much more going on in the
center and on his King so we cannot
easily play on if we can pawn like Lexie
form okay um d 5 is justice move
screaming out to be played for night f4
and then e6 is the absolute a big
weakness he on the board he also takes a
long time here
it's pretty awful Oh Kim
ko ko Kim huh yeah it's interesting okay
I think I'll just take the pond i was
thinking i can i can also try to play
more vigorously for the e6 square so
night / chat voice grade so i'm going to
prepare that come on why am i missing
those those little kinder gone tricks
all the time I mean this can barely
called a trick
yeah then I'm sitting in a damp in this
is 94
and this always annoys me to no end time
learning stumbling into something that
simple
check check check check check check
check check check check black for fits
on time oh my god yeah I know I simply
have a very low rate of seeing simple
things at the moment yeah your black is
okay of course I mean probably not
better or anything but not sure maybe
his bail went with this damn probably
black as bad I am I pawns are but weaker
so yeah it's a scramble yes no time I
wanted to check here how to him how to
kill this off here white is just in
fantastic shape so big stakes okay easy
assist or maybe just insert this one
definitely I said okay this is also very
good yeah this is already not not that
great damn it it also didn't like the
move
this is what the engine gives strongly
stronger 86 I can take here yellow again
night be five I mean ridiculous just
ridiculous stuff you know this is always
check so yeah yeah yeah just over I
Hannah be sure basics is the easiest
move ever I mean I was happy that I'm
not losing instantly I hear this b5
takes 94 wow that's a cool line by the
engine but not so realistic for glitz
glam and why it is okay yeah yeah yeah
but tricky business tricky business yeah
at the end we had some scramble check
that wasn't particularly great probably
check your here shining fine jack so
again no time check yeah and he
overstepped the time okay so at least I
win at the end thanks for watching